so after senator lindsey graham south
carolina criticized dr fauci for his
silence on the problems with covet at
the border fauci responded saying
his call i have nothing to do with the
border despite what the high rates of
migrants testing positive
at joe's facilities that are now in our
country you know the cages that
all those kids are living on top of each
other in in fact the situation is so
dire the biden administration is now
pleading with nasa
to get their employees to volunteer
at these overcrowded migrant facilities
meanwhile after governor greg abbott
faced widespread backlash over
his decision to lift all coveted
restrictions in texas
oh cases continue to fall as the state
continues to reopen
when pressed about why this is happening
well dr fauci who a year ago
on 60 minutes said not to wear a mask
master useless he was unable to come up
with an answer here take a look
you know it's it can be confusing
because you may see a lag
and a delay because often you have to
wait a few weeks
before you see the effect of what you're
doing right now
you know there are a lot of things that
go into that i mean
when you say that they've they've had a
lot of
uh activity on the outside like ball
games
i'm not really quite sure it could be
they're doing things outdoors
far from the actual time that fauci has
been uh
confused or wrong about the virus as a
matter of fact he's been wrong
quite a bit take a look right now in the
united states
people should not be walking around with
masks
you're sure of it because people are
listening really no closely to this
right now people should not be white
there's no reason to be walking around
with a mask
when you're in the middle of an outbreak
wearing a mask might make people
feel a little bit better and it might
even block
a droplet but it's not providing the
perfect protection that people think
that it is and often there are
unintended consequences dr fauci it's
saturday morning in america people are
waking up right now with real concerns
about this they want to go to malls and
movies maybe the gym
as well should we be changing our habits
and if so how
no right now at this moment there is no
need to change
anything that you're doing on a
day-by-day basis
right now the risk is still low but this
could change i've said that
many times even on this program you've
got to watch out because although the
risk is low now
you don't need to change anything you're
doing when you start to see
community spread yeah this could change
and force you to
become much more attentive to doing
things that would protect you from
spread
here with reaction south carolina
senator lindsey graham senator great to
have you back
uh you went down there now twice to the
border
19 senators went down there by the way
thank you for sharing your videos you
ted cruz and others because
my cameras that were with you were not
allowed in because of the
the media blackout kids on top of kids
on top of kids
high positivity rate i would think dr
fauch would be concerned about that
and and that's my point i'm not here to
beat up dr fauci
he is the medical advisor to the
president of the united states joe biden
joe biden has confidence in dr fauci joe
biden
was concerned about people attending the
texas rangers
opening day baseball game because it may
be a super spreading event
here's what i would tell president biden
you need to send your medical advisor to
the border because it's a complete
chaotic situation you've got
600 people in a room built for 80. you
had 172
000 illegal immigrants show up on our
border in march alone
with a 10 percent positive rate i'm not
asking dr fauci
to change our immigration laws i'm
asking him to visit the border
and give his analysis of what's going
there on there regarding
the pandemic i can't believe the vice
president has not gone to the border
the president hasn't gone to the border
and the chief medical advisor
to this state has not gone to the border
it's important that dr fauci see for
himself
what's going on at the border because if
he saw what i saw
i think he would recommend that we
change our policies senator
we're sending these migrants to every
state
as other senators said everybody is
being let in
then they're being sent to other states
huge unfunded mandate
shelter food health care education that
now falls on the backs of the taxpayers
expecting maybe two two and a half
million people this year maybe more
and my question to you is we have laws
in this country you're a law maker
lawmaker
if i aid in a bet in law breaking why do
i think i'd end up in jail
you know that's a really good question
so what happens if you're 16 or
under you're going to be kept in the
country you're going to be released
into the country eighty percent of the
unaccompanied minors have family
members already in america they have a
phone number
so they pay smugglers the family member
sends money back to say guatemala
they'll hire smuggler get them to the
border and the federal government will
finish the last mile we're aiding and
betting human trafficking
it's 800 a day to keep one of these kids
in u.s custody
but we your federal government is
uniting
the illegal immigrant child with the
illegal immigrant parent
and don't you think that's going to
encourage more illegal immigration
and the confinement situation if that's
not a super spreading event i don't know
what is
i can't believe that the top level of
the government hasn't
visited the border it just is dr fauci
when it comes to looking at the border
question are you certain republicans
will unite
and they won't be able to end the
legislative filibuster are you confident
lisa murkowski ben
sasse mitt romney won't go along with
that
uh yeah i'm confident well let's put it
this way if we don't unite and stop the
filibuster that's the end of the
republican party
and the conservative cause and we'll
have nobody to blame but ourselves
so yeah i think the answer is yes we
would senator graham thank you as always